hello everyone and welcome to the
playoffs of the 2019 Singh field cup its
Magnus Carlsen versus Bingley Hren and
two of the rapid games have already been
played and the both of the rapid games
have ended in a draw then a surprise to
everyone Bing was able to win the first
game of the blitz and that was really
exciting since Magnus Carlsen has not
only never lost the playoffs but he was
never he was never down in points in the
playoffs so it's very interesting can
cross and get back here with the white
pieces to get back into the match
because the way it goes is first there
are two rapid gains then they have six
blitz games which is basically three
mini matches of two blitz games if you
win either of any blitz mini bullets
match then you just win the single Cup
and if all the six blitz games are drawn
then you don't go immediately into the
Armageddon it was some sort of a weird
rule where the arbiters decide on what
happens then whether they play more
blitz games whether it's normal given
maybe days you know consult with the
players four or something but yeah that
being said let's check out the game and
also it's very interesting in 2017
champions showdown if you remember the
match cost and versus Dingley rent
Magnus defeated being ten to one in
rapids and six to one and a half in
blitz so really just destroying him but
now he's down in points and he has the
white pieces so let's see what happens
Carlson opens with efore and it's I
think said in an interview after the
game in in the first game of the blitz
that he won he said he flagged Magnus
Magnus lost some time but he said that
it was it was really intense both with
him only a few seconds on the clock that
he didn't see the win that was very
surprised when the orbiter said that
Magnus lost some time now Carson has to
get back into the game with E 5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5
calls and chooses the rule opus for a
must-win game with a 6 more of his
defensive brush up to a4 and now Knight
to f6 with castles by Magnus and Bishop
to e7 with d3 and now b5 pushing the
bishop back Bishop to b3 and d6 Oh
the stuff with c3 making room for the
bishop and c2 nights the a5 attacking
the bishop bishop the c2 and now
c5 justin grabbing the center and now
the common move here is rook to e1 but
as this is a blitz game and cross and
it's the win he decides to mix it up he
plays d4 right away C capture some B for
C captures and now there is one game
where Queen to c7 was played but here
doing just castles and it is as a move
11 in the reuleaux PES that we have a
completely new game h3 by Carlsen not
allowing Bishop to g4 or or 94 for that
matter and now rook to e8 with d5
grabbing more space in the center just
closing the position not allowing any
trace of pieces as he needs this to be
as complicated as possible he needs to
play as fast as possible and not
allowing any drawing chances Bishop to
d7 biding preparing to bring the rook
over to D only open file on the board
that is the C file Knights the c3 and
now Queen to b8 the other rook is coming
to the c8 we have Bishop to d3 and now
comes Luke the c8 as planned
Knights - E - now and sorry that's B -
rights to e2 and here we have nice - b7
this Knight is now coming to c5 from
where it's gonna harass the bishop on b3
and you can't really bring this over
rook over to c1 since this bishop is
still undeveloped developed the target
is Bishop back to be one so Crossan goes
for g f-- g for a preparing g5 to kick
away the night at some point Knights the
c5 and now just night the g3 this knife
can outcome either to f5 or h5 depending
on what happens in the game ending
decides to eliminate a white light
square bishop which is a huge
accomplishment for black if this was a
classical game you would never see this
in a game between carlson and dink
but it's a blitz game so anything goes
as this is a must-win game for Magnus
tonight captures on d3
Queen captures on d3 and now before
clearing the be 5 square for blacks
light square Bishop ding wants to win
material here always a nice move
especially in a blitz game rook to e1
getting the rock out of the way and now
Queen B 5 ding
the trade Queens as deemed only needs a
draw in this game to win the single Cup
as he already won one game Queen B one
cost and of course declines the trade
and now rook the c7 ding is now getting
ready at double of rooks and the C file
with Bishop to e3 by Magnus and now rook
a to c8 and now Knight to d2 this Knight
is now not yet ready but the constant is
preparing b3 and then create to create a
nice output for the knight on c4 with g6
biding first taking away the f5 squared
from Carlson's night and then now b3 now
it would be dangerous to bring your rook
over to c2 because you can just you know
disconnect the rooks with Knight to the
c-4 so Queen the b7 ding knows Knight to
c4 is coming so he's preparing Bishop to
b5 to try and kick away the knife from
c4 Crossan continues knife to c4 and now
comes in Bishop to b5 s plan and now
Knight to a5 which is really an odd move
because where is this night ever going
to go from here well it can go to c6 but
that all depends on what in place so you
can't go to the dark squares here you
have to move to b8 Queen to be 8 and now
comes Queen to d2
now the other route can enter the game
as well rook the sea 3 by think also the
b4 point is under attack so rook the c3
just defends the pawn as well and now a
3 by cousin so what do you play here
here being finds a very nice idea and
such a wonderful active play for a
boyd's game B captures an a3 now
allowing Knight to c6 which basically
traps things
rook over here but then calculates
precisely with Bishop captures on c6
Queen captures and c3 grabbing the
exchange but now ding eliminates the e
the d5 point the rush of characters on
d5 opening opening up an attack against
cousins Queen Queen to a5 and now Bishop
captures on e4 this is just this is just
awesome as this is not an easy line to
calculate Crossing is attacking the
bishop at this point this point and it's
hard to calculate this especially with
little time on the clock and heads they
both have but the dink plays it with
bunch of characters on e4
it seems that it loses a piece after g5
and yes
across the best bet here is Knight
captures Knight captures and just Queen
captures on a3 and the game continues
you know it's it's still anything it
happened especially in the Blitz game
but Carson says no I want to win a piece
here so he plays g5 but here
Bing finds dink finds an absolute beast
move so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this move being played in
the position while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
such such a beast move and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
ding finds it Bishop to AAA just getting
the bishop out of there and daring
Magnus to capture the knight on f6
because here if Magnus captures for
example G captures on f6 you get Queen -
b7 threatening mate and even though you
don't lose it with white black ensures a
draw here because the only way to
prevent me this King f1 and now you get
Queen - G to check King E - n - Queen f3
check and you have to go back to f1 and
that link Oh the only thing ding needs
to win the sinful Cup is a draw so after
king d2 if you decide you don't want to
draw then you're getting made it rush up
to d8 you try to take away the 5th rank
from the White Queen so you can deliver
Queen d5 check and after Queen before
you're getting Queen to d5 check now
with ideas of Bishop to a5 just winning
the Queen so came to e2 you have to move
it away and now rook the c2 check Bishop
to b2 and now a5 just wins as the Queen
is no longer able to protect the bishop
here the Queen has to move but you know
where we gonna move the Queen
so next move black just wins so Carlsen
decided of course he cannot allow such
even even though he doesn't have to
calculate anything he sees it's a it's a
quick repetition draw by repetition so
he plays Queen captures on a6
it's the second best move recommended by
the engine actually Knights the d5 by
dink and now comes Bishop to e7 and not
allowing Knight captures on e3 attacking
dings Queen and now Queen to c7
going controlling the C file and now we
have rook eat the c1 cross and tries to
get them to move the Queen then of
course Rho capture son c8 would be
wonderful but dink had all of this
planned out
rook Queen captures and c1 width trek
rook captures and now rook captures and
c1 with check King to h2 and out push up
to c6 getting the best part of harm's
way once this dark square bishop moves
the bishop would be under attack so here
first thing sacrificed in exchange now
he gives up the the Queen for two rooks
very exciting stuff and he also has a
passed pawn here sorry that's Queen a
passed pawn here on a3 which is very
dangerous and very close to becoming the
queen so Carlsen grabs it Queen captures
an a3 and now Bishop captures on g5 and
here still a very long time on the clock
Carson has to play 92 he has to take the
f4 Square from from black but instead he
decides to go for the active plant Queen
captures on d6 now Carson's plan is
Bishop to c5 followed by Bishop to F
sorry I better the c5 followed by Queen
to f8 checkmate
dink however plays Bishop to f4 he says
I'm not afraid of your Bishop to c5 move
I'm just gonna pin your night with
Bishop to c5 by Magnus and here it just
doesn't work even though Crossing is
threatening made here feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
move for ding liran which would win him
the Sinquefield Cup if he finds it well
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just created
the mortal play of this game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the move is not Bishop to h6 this
prevents this mate but you run into this
mate Queen d8 check King g7 Bishop f8
check King f6 and now you're just
getting made at Queen b6 Queen yet check
King e6 and Queen to d6 is made because
the night covers on the DF v square
however if we found Knight to e7 then
you have just created the immortal
playoffs game because there is there is
no defense against the rook the h1 mate
by defending mate and well of course
temporarily sacrificing this night of
course if the Queen captures it to
threaten make her again then rook to h1
is checkmate the bishop controls the h1
square and other than this there is no
good move here for for Magnus he has to
play something there's no stopping rook
to h1 f3 is not even move if you play f3
just Bishop captures you haven't really
achieved anything here still the knight
is pinned you cannot move it
sorry if I forgot to mention that after
this matrix h1 you cannot capture since
the knight is pinned I'm sure you all
saw that but yeah after 97 there is
nothing to do here if you play Queen
captures and sees it's you just get
Knight captures and then it's just ding
is just up up a full rook which is
unplayable of course so really amazing
stuff Knight to e7 the immortal play of
the game there you have it
dinkler and wins the sinful cup and he's
the first person ever to beat Magnus
Carlsen in playoffs not only that he
defeated him in playoffs without losing
a single game he drew to rapid games and
then beat him in two blitz games which
is just insane but then again bingler
and I believe was at one point the
highest-rated blitz player in the world
so it's not all that all that mysterious
but yeah Carlsen smiled at the end of
the match really congratulating and
after in an interview he said that ding
just played better so it's really not
surprising that he won really again
well showing class also in defeat as
it's very important so really exciting
stuff III thought about showing you some
other games from the playoffs but my
computer froze and I had some problems
still haven't figure out why that's
happening so I decided to only show this
one call it the immortal play of the
game I do hope you enjoyed that but yeah
that's the game I hope you enjoyed it
and I hope you enjoyed my short coverage
of the single Cup now we are going to
turn to some other things that we have
to cover some Benko games and then we're
going back to the cup of Blanca saga few
more games left and then we are starting
a new saga which of course you you all
will vote
so that's the game as usual you can
check two of my previous videos you're
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon continuing with what everything I
just said so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day